Hello, Dr. Kevin Connors here with section 17 of my book Stop Fighting Cancer. Hopefully you're learning something you're getting something from this to take back to your doctor or whatever you're working with
Really, again, we're doing this because I know that we can't help everybody that's out there. We just don't have space in our office. It's not possible. I mean, it is impossible
and I know that not everybody could come to our office. So we're trying to be a blessing. Remember we talked about the bias that's out there taking advice from bias people. And I said that I have a bias too. You know, my bias is what people in my office and I need to make a living.
But I'm giving away a book. I'm giving away a program to people. I know they will never come in my office. So please understand I have no bias other than you getting better.
So I just want you to make the best decisions. I want you to be able to have enough wisdom to take it before the Lord so that he can lead you in the right way.
And I want you to have success ultimately. So take this information to your doctor. I mean, he probably won't know what to do with it.
But maybe you have a natural path or some natural medicine doctor or functional medicine doctor that you can go to that maybe can gain some wisdom from this and help lead you in your course if you're not able to do it on your own.
So please be appreciative of what we're trying to do here. Support us as much as you can with prayer. I ask this section. We're talking about boosted your immune system. And what we're talking about with your immune system is we want to boost your TH one side.
So this little teeter totter shows this person has a hyper TH two side. And this is what usually happens if you remember the previous sections with kids or patients.
They're TH two dominant at the site of cancer. And what happens with chemotherapy patients. So the chemotherapy patient somebody who is going through chemotherapy or went through chemotherapy will be TH two dominant everywhere in their body.
So their immune system, their killer side of their immune system is extremely suppressed if not completely in the pits. That's why if you go through chemo, they have to measure your white blood cells before they give you another chemo therapy.
Because if it's really in the pits, they could kill you with the chemo.
So they have to sometimes wait a few days or weeks or give you some medication that will stimulate you know an immediate immune response to to be able to administer the next chemo therapy drug.
That's the negative of chemotherapy is it just shoots your immune system because that's a rapidly replicating cell structure as well. That's what chemotherapy targets.
So we need to stimulate an immune response. Now in this section, you're going to read about a whole bunch of different things that will help boost that TH one side of your immune system.
Maybe the greatest thing I get is food, but there's a lot of different supplements that you could use to stimulate that TH one side.
So read through this stuff and make sure in any supplementation protocol, I mean you can always go to our website and go to our store and purchase some of this stuff from designs for health and other things that we have in our personal store.
There's nothing illegal or anything about doing that. I encourage you to do that instead of buying some cheap stuff and some, you know, pharmacist store that doesn't really know anything about supplementation.
When you're talking about herbs and supplements, you don't want to buy synthetic, you don't want to buy herbs that are just cheaply grown. Unfortunately, maybe fortunately, there's no FDA guidelines on this. So you have to trust a good company.
So most of the companies that sell solely through doctors are good companies. And I'd recommend those. So you can look on our website if you still desire to purchase that way, but this will give you a good list of a lot of immune stimulants. So I hope you enjoy this section and I will see you soon.